her elbow goes in then look this is eel
you think if might keep it that
way so
in here then movement this
way L to the yin line and his elbow went
from the y y line to the yin line okay
as my elbow passes into Chon his elbow
is going around I'm affecting his elbow
okay and as my elbow goes up his elbow's
traveling that way in space you should
feel his
elbow then you'll always I'm doing
everything want to do that you're
good do
it as I do this it's very
small don't go too
far okay
feel what you're doing if I go too far
I'll close it
off just far
enough this way that
one this way out and I add to that some
movement you get more out
without my arm actually taking my elbow
outside my shoulder
bline this way turn I take a step you'll
get more out
going but my elbow never goes outside my
shoulder one I'm never going like this
to do
that El out
turn step my hand comes straight my
center it's not that I
turn and turn him the
rules different can you see that look at
my movement that's my
rotation straight
attention here head
already falling from the angle that I
here like
this and then I'm going to take this and
it becomes a a a
push boom it's
same
this okay it's exactly the
same okay gaing it in the same way that
we did that other so as he got that loop
I dropped underneath you you pay
attention moving oh my duck under here
and I just with his
hand according to that
grip okay so what I mean by that is
you're going to pin this
shoulder okay and so that hand should be
underneath that midline
of the grid then then it has your weight
okay and that's where your strike is on
that same line
around there's the line right here
that's where I push down straight and
then there's your strike straight
should grid rules like you move with